hey guys just want to let you know now
starting to get some dates on the books
uh september 16th through 18th i'll be
at the phoenix house of comedy this is a
makeup show
uh from before the virus and uh go to
ryansickler.com for all my live dates
you'll start to see them there i
also want to let you know this is
something people been asking for years
people have been saying
you got to make a ringtone of your laugh
i don't know why anybody would want that
i can't understand why anybody would
want to hear that on their phone
but after years of messages comments
i did it we got ringtones of my laugh
coming
i promise you we'll put a promo out and
blast it out so you know where to get
them
but uh i heard yous and you're about to
hear me on your phone all the time all
right
this episode of the honeydew is brought
to you by expressvpn
more on that later let's get into the do
the honeydew
with ryan zickler
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
studios i'm ryan sickler
ryan sickler.com ryan sickler on all
social media
uh i want to say thank you very much for
your support the messages
the emails everything that i get uh is
so supportive and i really do appreciate
you guys i'm glad you like the show i
love doing it we're bringing you more
and more
make sure you subscribe to the youtube
channel don't just watch hit that
subscribe tell everybody you know about
it
and the patreon the honeydew with you
all is
just it's so much fun i i mean
again i can't tell you the crazy stories
we're hearing
uh and that community is growing and
growing so keep the stories coming
hopefully i get to do an episode with
you
sign up it's only five bucks a month
there are no other tiers levels or
anything like that it's five bucks
uh you get an episode a week audio and
video you get access to the whole back
catalog
and if you do it for a year you'll save
on over a month of free episodes all
right
as you guys know i record here at santa
monica music center i want to tell you
about something we have going on here
right now we're working
uh with the uh at-risk youth and the
santa monica police department
on a program that lana does here called
otto which is outreach through the arts
um right now we've got some young kids
here learning how to podcast learning
about cameras graphics
uh all that good stuff so uh we're
giving back to the community teaching
these kids possibly they want to get in
front of it they're coming up with ideas
everything so
we got a lot of that stuff going on if
you're looking to get into podcasts or
anything you live locally
there's space for uh rent in culver city
at the culver city music store you can
go there um and check it all out so
keep an eye out i'll be promoting these
kids and what they've got going on here
now that that is all out of the way you
know what we do over here we highlight
the low lights these are the stories
behind the storytellers
uh it is a pleasure to have this
storyteller back on the do y'all ladies
and gentlemen
justin martindale welcome back to the
dude we're back
happy anniversary this is actually first
time here
this is yeah the first time i was here
was this time last year yes and you were
ymh with me last time yeah
studio so thank you for coming cheers
cheers um
thank you for having me out here because
today i'd probably just be
sitting in a dry bathtub listening to
driver's lap
driver's license that oh that drive have
you heard the driver's license song oh
god if you want to oh yes i have that
girl there
i saw the snl sketch yeah if you want to
cut that's the song to do it's a twitter
song oh yeah
man uh well before we get into some of
the stuff that we're gonna talk about
today you know how we do it please plug
everything and anything you would like
um yeah i will be
on tour no that's not right um i will
nope not doing that either actually
i actually have some my venmo is justin
dash martindale
um i have a birthday coming up
this will be my second quarantined
birthday so
yeah hit me up i'm shirtless in my
profile pic you're welcome
um that's that's really that's really no
actually i have a
amazing podcast thank you there we go
no um i have an amazing podcast with my
friend justine moreno
um comedian and um
uh insta thought i think she's an insta
thought now
um called glitter and garbage and
that is available on spotify and itunes
so we are bringing you
more fun episodes we've had guests on
like um trixie mattel we've had um
uh brian friedman amazing choreographer
to britney spears and
beyonce we've had janie mccarthy we've
had
amazing guests um so yeah check that out
on itunes and spotify all right glitter
and garbage glitter and garbage check it
out yeah
now if you want to hear justin's
backstory and everything go check out
his first episode here on the dues it's
fantastic it's a good one
i actually had a lot of listeners hit me
up and
like i made some new some do friends
from it they were like
we loved you yeah we got like a little
dude a little dude they're great people
yeah everybody here they're good fans
i'm blown away excuse me see it chokes
me up how good they are oh god where's
the journal
listen justin asked me who takes the
cake the crown
for the biggest crier i want to know if
it was jeremiah
yeah if we if we put back in the [ __ ] we
had to cut out
it'd be a two-hour episode subscribe to
his patreon
first and only guess we had to stop down
and bring tissues in
you know so
[Laughter]
anyhow uh let's jump right into it
because we've got a few stories to tell
here today
um let's start with a dui okay
before we do sure how old are you i
was 23 so just
stupid all right so leading up to that
are you
drinking when does drinking start in
your life uh
drinking started like
high school like 16 17. yeah and were
you drinking a lot all the time or was
this just a bad night um
was it was it this was a
just one of those nights that like damn
it i wish i would have
stayed home because it turned into
it always does not being a dui all
that's here so that was the whole
one frustrating oh yes this is the worst
this is one of those moments in my life
that i was just like
how do i put it lightly if i could
describe it in like one word it would be
[ __ ] like that's that's literally
how it was um okay so and one of these
stories that i'm going to share today
actually leads into
this story there's layers there always
there's some blankets and some throw
rugs and whatnots um
so yes i was um
working in northern california
um i had spent two summers in lake tahoe
doing um working for the lake tahoe
shakespeare festival
because i don't know if you know but
this face screams
shakespeare um yes i was a master
thespian um an out and proud thespian
i was doing like leading man [ __ ] i was
crushing are you othello
oh yes clearly
you get me um so i had been
hired after that summer to go
do the performance at the um
where the theater is based it was based
in uh nevada city which is in california
northern california small town main
street
you know nothing really going on there
um so
i got to stay on after the season and do
a rehearsal and everything so
once the rehearsals and once the show
started going we
i think we were doing like a tech night
or like it the show might have even
opened up
already um we had gone out that night to
celebrate
and we went to a couple bars meeting
some of the cast members
we stayed out until like the bars closed
and the thing about
being that far out is there's no city
lights you were like
you have the mountains and the moon yeah
that is the
that's it so you have to be
you know coherent to drive because
there's twists and turns on those
mountains that you could fall off of
oh tiger woods too soon
and so um
i decided that i was going to be the
designated driver now i'm a tall guy i'm
a big guy i can handle my alcohol
especially now since i'm not
drinking it anymore but
um then you know we're shutting them
shutting down bars like my cast members
are just shit-faced and i'm like okay
i'll drive everyone home
because i need to get everyone home so
you're not only driving yourself you're
driving other people
you know the lead of the show is with me
you know and he's a tiny tiny dude and
he's
[ __ ] up i got macbeth in the basement
yeah right
that's who bruce hey um romeo shut the
[ __ ] up
try to drive testimonials yourself too
julia testimony
um so um
we're at one bar and we decide it's last
call we're gonna have a shot right let's
just do a shot
how many people are you gonna drive i
have two in the car with me
two plus you through wha what are we
driving
i am driving a
ford explorer sport okay all right
oh you're now having a round of shots
before you drive
before yes yeah yes so i was like okay
i'll take a shot of jack that's fine
so i took a shot of jack get in the car
we have to loop around
how many drinks did you had prior to the
shop oh i was ha it was like maybe
honestly like two bud lights okay so
nothing like
good so get in the car
pull around and we have to get on the
main street so i pull into this empty
lot
and right when i say this i'm looking
around and i'm like damn there's a lot
of cops out tonight because it's also
the end of the month
and there there was a lot of people
partying that night
as i'm pulling into the parking lot i'm
pulling out onto the main street
[Music]
and i'm like you're kidding me right now
what
so pull over guy next to me is just like
like speaking and like speaking some
like
gibberish soliloquy and uh
i'm like be cool be cool and so
this cop comes over to my window [ __ ]
hot
oh god this
hot cop just i was waiting for the porn
music to start just
like wow like i was waiting
and um roll the window down of course
i'm like
yes he's like do you know why i pulled
you over and i'm like
well i could name a couple reasons i
didn't say that but it was in my must
say
it was in my mind i'm like yeah no and
he goes you went down
you went down a one-way or you you went
into a one-way parking lot
mind you there's no cars in this and i'm
like i didn't see this sign he's like
yeah it's at the front and i look over
there is literally a branch covering
this one-way sign
and there's again no cars it's a it's a
it's a grocery store
parking lot so he's like have you had
anything to drink and i'm like i've had
a couple yes and he goes um
what are you doing and i'm like well i'm
driving home obviously
there's a little bit of banter all this
stuff and then um
they asked me to get a banter or i am
back pentameter
i am the pentameter four
five five um
i didn't want to throw in the like i'm
performing up the street yeah yeah
do you know who you pulled over
you still got your ruffle around your
neck
the theater like the mask i have the
skull yeah
or an orex
[Laughter]
um uh so i so they so they
they're talking it's it's a it's hot cop
and like another cup
and um so they're talking whatever they
ask me to get out of the car so i get
out of the car
they then start talking to me they put a
light in my eyes
they're checking for like pupil dilation
everything i'm talking completely normal
and they even say they're like oh you're
talking
fine you're you're not slurring your
words okay but we're gonna give you this
breathalyzer test and i'm like okay
but before the breathalyzer test sorry
they give me the the line walk
yeah and i'm just like
just [ __ ] two two two to the moon
like
like living my like rupaul's drag race
maxi challenge runway fantasy um
which is fine they're just like great
walk and i'm like duh thank you
and uh so then they give me the
breathalyzer so i blow this breathalyzer
i this breathalyzer comes back like 2.8
like how yeah right how
and he's like well you blew a 2.8 i'm
like that means i'm dead
yeah you're dead my pupils are dilating
correctly
my language is fine i just did the line
he says well
the breathalyzer said you're shit-faced
and i'm like i wouldn't be driving if i
was shit-faced i'm
literally the designated driver we have
a show like tomorrow
we had a matinee the next day a matinee
remember matinees uh so
what do they do they slammed me on the
car really they pulled you out oh you
were already
the shame of it all slam you in the car
oh oh
i was like i doth protest
[Laughter]
just slam me on the card
get thee to a nunnery
[Laughter]
they but they slam me on the
on the hood of my car while the bars
are like now everyone
saw me everyone was like isn't that the
actor from up the street
um
isn't that big beth's yeah isn't his
name on the marquee
that's the justin martindale um
and i'm and i'm just i'm in handcuffs
and i'm just like oh like are you crying
be honest i was
no no no i was angry you know what's
happening do you know you're going to
jail right now for a dui oh
i just thought i was going to like sit
in the car for a hot second until they
figured it out
2.8 is ridiculous yeah so
after that they put me in the car and
everyone's like
damn look at that guy getting arrested
yeah
right i'll be back guys and
uh so they put me in the car and then
they're like okay we can either
tow your car or we can let
your friend drive it my friend is [ __ ]
face that's why i'm driving
he takes my car and i'm like dude don't
take my car he's like i got it
i can't even cover my mouth i'm like
and so they take me to the jail
and what's the jail in nevada city
california like
you would think there'd be more because
like you'd feel like there'd be like a
like a bigger
meth community i'm gonna say i feel like
it is a meth community it's not it was
actually very uh
it was nice refreshing i was the only
one there
and they were having a field day with
you oh yes
they were like oh we got this tall white
gay that just came in it was just like
this
unicorn that just got picked up from the
forest yes yeah they were like oh
what is this what is this majestic
beauty
oh yes so i walk in there they
they they thumb print me um
they took all they took my wallet they
might my phone
is dying like it's it was you know a
flip phone at the time
and it's like on its last leg
then they put me in this cell i remember
there was like a tom skerritt movie
in the lobby and i mind you i'm so i'm
like walking around i'm just like why
the [ __ ] am i here
they unhandcuffed me so i'm like in the
lobby
they thumb print me i said that um
and i go i'm sitting down waiting i
guess i'm being processed i don't know
at this point i feel like i'm in a
doctor's office but i'm not i'm in a
police station and i'm the only one
there tom skerritt's looking at me with
judgment
and um from the tv and uh i get up
to go get some water at the water
fountain and this
this officer's like sit down and i'm
like i need to get water and they're
like
you gotta ask permission i'm like okay
everyone needs to [ __ ] relax
just calm down this is i'm like i'm
still in this like there's a big
misunderstanding
like mind frame so then
they put me in a cell there's nothing in
there i'm the only one in there thank
god
um what time of morning is it this is
like i mean
at this point it's like three yeah and
there's nowhere to like sit there's
nowhere to like
lay down so i laid down on my body just
kind of shuts down and it's like
go to bed it's late so i lay down on the
floor
and i kind of doze off i doze off
i wake up at five o'clock in the morning
to a swift boot kick
to the ribs bam oh
full-on kick in the ribs and i look up
and i'm like i remember just wincing
because i was like what the [ __ ]
and um turns out cracked three of my
ribs no
you know i was a frail youth
and this guy i look up and it's this cop
and he turned the lights on
horrible horrible fluorescent lights
and he's like martindale get out of here
before we change our mind and i'm like
this [ __ ]
and so so wait he cracked three your
[ __ ] ribs kicked me in the
like i'm at like a cop booth just bam
like like you could say probably steel
toe
oh yeah yo it was it hurt like but again
adrenaline i was still in that
everything was kind of processing and it
hurt
but like i didn't know the extent of
like how bad it hurt and also you could
say like
good morning sunshine or yeah hello
handsome are you still asleep but
they didn't want to say that with me so
anyways i get a boot kick to the ribs
get out of here before we change our
mind i'm like well what am i what am i
supposed to do and they go you better
figure that out before we change our
minds and i'm like
what uh so they give me back my phone
they give me back
they don't give me back my money they
took my money
gave me a check in the amount of like
whatever the [ __ ] it was like seven
dollars
my phone's dead it's pouring rain
outside
and i don't know where i'm at i don't
have anybody's phone number
you know this is before like you know
iphones and [ __ ] so i don't know
i don't know my stage manager's number i
don't know anybody's number off the top
of my head they
had these are like san francisco numbers
northern california numbers
so what do i do i decide i'm gonna walk
so i don't know where i'm at i finally
figure out okay there's the highway
so i decide that i'm going to walk
down the highway in the pouring rain
it's
freezing you're a nut this is like this
is like
and this is like do you have your did
they take your shoelaces and all that
[ __ ]
no no i would have rather hanged myself
honestly
honestly if they i mean i didn't even
think about it was just so i just
remember it being like it was like
early november
four or five o'clock in the morning i'm
freezing and alone i'm walking down this
highway it's pouring down rain
every [ __ ] 18-wheeler is driving by
me like
i'm like oh my god this is it this is
how i die
honestly um so finally i think i walked
nine miles
damn yeah i walked nine miles to finally
i got to an
exit that i was familiar with and it was
the stage manager's exit
who who was you know running the show or
whatever so i walk i'm like okay i know
where i'm at i know where i'm at i know
where i'm at just a few more
i'm exhausted and my ribs are
[ __ ] broken when do you find that out
i mean i could just tell
it was like i was like wincing like it
was like
oh like every time i breathe there's
nothing you can do for those no
i knew i knew um
i knew there was cracked ribs in there
and so i finally make it to his house
the sun's coming out i knock on his door
he opens the door and he's like what are
you doing i mean i couldn't even imagine
like what he
saw like i'm sure he was like did i just
watch the ring
like like did some like like asian girl
crawl out of a tv
like what is this like what is this hot
wet mess and and i just
i i then show them my fingers and
they're all you know
processed and uh black and blue from the
fingerprinting
and i'm like i went to jail and he's
like what
so i dry off i lay down i get like a
couple minutes of sleep on his couch i
wake up
the next day i have to go to a show
so i show up and ever like my state like
everyone's freaking out because they
knew
john we'll call it a job hold on real
quick
we'll call it mark mark that ass yeah
just bleep i'll just say i'll say so the
guy
so the guy that i was driving he
made it to where he told the director
like oh justin's been in jail like they
arrested him
so my whole crew and everything's
freaking out my director at the time
goes to the police who she's a native of
the town goes to the police station
cusses them out she's like what the [ __ ]
are you doing he's not from here like
what
what like where is he and they're like
we don't know didn't give a [ __ ]
and so i get there she's pissed off
she's i can't believe that happened to
you
you know everyone's like what happened
and it sucks because i knew i was like
doing right and being responsible
and now everyone kind of looks at me
like right yeah you're the problem
you're you're all right this is you were
drinking and driving and i'm like no
i would [ __ ] do it so anyways
we do the show the show must go on you
know of course
especially shakespeare especially
shakespeare
so um afterwards i
end up calling um
uh the court because once the show is
over
i'm leaving the town i'm going back home
to texas i'm driving back to texas
yeah yeah and so i'm not gonna be here
for the court date that they'd given me
so i call them
and i'm like yeah just let you know i
got arrested and
i didn't really hear anything back and
i'm not gonna be here
so what do i do and the lady is just
like well i wouldn't worry
about i go okay i don't have to worry
about this and she's like yeah if you're
going to be out of state there's
there's nothing really you know we can
do it i'm like okay cool hang up
leave go back to texas come back another
summer
to work in nevada yes to do another
summer
then after that summer i moved to la for
the first time
okay so i'm driving around
i'm just wondering is that on your
record when you get back together
i'm sorry i drive by i drop after that
summer i came back to la for the second
time
so the second time i'm here to this day
right
so i'm driving around in beverly hills i
just got this new job
i'm driving around in beverly hills this
[ __ ] prick
cop on a bike i wish i was like where's
the hot one
like this guy was just like seriously
terminator 2
like that cop like the the liquid silver
cop
he pulls me over and he's like on a bike
on a bike
he pulls me over because i'm trying to
even think i want to say i either rolled
through a stop sign
or i had a um
or like one of my lights was that i
can't remember um
but he pulls me over like right when i'm
out in front of work too like i'm
literally at work and i'm right there
pulled over
right in
and i'm like i am fortune's fool
yes
[Laughter]
i'm just like you've got to be kidding
me so i give him my license
and he's like and he's on a bike and
he's on a bike
god god leads it up against your car
just so much attitude yeah yeah
yeah he's like you're that shakespeare
[ __ ] right
and i'm like well my reputation precedes
me um
[Laughter]
so he um gets my license and he's like
this license has been suspended for two
years
and i'm like what he's like yes you also
have um
you have a um a warrant
it's not it wasn't a benchmark
it was something it was just the license
was suspended right
so then they tow my car
right there on the spot right there on
the spot they pull up call a towing
company
they tow my car do you realize do you
put together quickly this is because of
the dui or you don't know
no i'm just like what and they're like
yeah you have a um
you have a uh uh an
extended extended ticket or something in
nevada city so i'm like ah [ __ ]
so they take my car it's in an impound
and then
um uh i get it out and
i had i started another job and
like i had like these bounty hunter guys
show up at my job
and they arrest me at my job so i get
arrested
i at work yes wait why because so they
let you go
right there though so they just took
your car yeah they just took my car
got it and how much longer this was this
is um
they just randomly show up at your where
are you working where was the new job uh
the new job was west hollywood yeah it
was like and they walk right into your
job
these three guys came up to me and they
were like yeah we're looking for justin
and i was like
i'm him and they're like all right i was
like what the [ __ ]
so yeah got arrested got taken down
beverly hills
uh police station beautiful beautiful
place beautiful
beautiful really good yeah tons of
organic food
and um filtered water um
and so they were like oh yeah you have
an arrest warrant out for
this thing in in nevada city that was a
couple years ago or whatever and i'm
like what
mind you i'm dating this new person
and i'm like hey i'm in jail
which is what everybody wants to hear on
the other end of like oh i'm seeing this
great guy
yeah so i get out of jail
i have to then um uh
get my car and drive it to nevada city
to go figure this the [ __ ] out and i'm
so mad because i'm like
oh not only have i been like embarrassed
and
shamed and like in the you know bleakest
of weather down a highway and
my ribs have been broken and i had to
tell my mom and she like came out to
drive with me to go take care of it yeah
and so my court date is at like five
o'clock in the morning on this
whatever [ __ ] morning and [ __ ]
nevada
5 a.m it was like an early early early
quarter
i remember i remember like getting my
bearings like waking up and just being
like okay i've got this
like i'm panicked you know i'm just like
what the [ __ ] gonna happen
so we get into the courthouse they're
like okay martindale versus
nevada city shakespeare players
and and the the the judge is like
oh yeah we don't have anything for this
this this this case has been dropped
and i'm like what and they're like oh
yeah the the cop
doesn't work here anymore hot cop had
been transferred
so he can't be there and they were like
yeah there's there's uh insufficient
evidence on this so
case has been dropped it's off your
record have a great day and i'm like
that's it that is it
the [ __ ] that i went through i mean not
only did i pay for
an impounding fee for like a month how
much is that oh god i don't even it was
like
several thousands of dollars that i
didn't have i had and i
you know moved into a new place in west
hollywood i had a you know a new job
everything got taken from me like that
and
my car i couldn't i couldn't make
payments on my car so
my mom took the car back to texas
and sold it so for 10 plus years i
didn't have a car out here in l.a is
that right
because it [ __ ] me up it [ __ ] me
up so you just did ubers and i just did
ubers and lifts i
walked everywhere if it was walking
distance i would ask friends for rides
i just did not have a car because i was
like
i'd never want to deal with that again i
don't trust anybody
i don't trust myself like
it was awful so
knowing that i got this dui taken off my
record i was very angry of course
just because i was like wow i went
through all that [ __ ]
for nothing yeah like i don't understand
how
the court could be like oh yeah this has
been dropped
this is off your record oh yeah but like
all the other [ __ ] still
applied you know right
so yeah that was that was when did you
finally get a car how long
september of last year of 2020 yep how
about you now
because of ours you decided to drive
well because a lot of roads are great
right now
well no everything a was on fire
literally
there was a fire around us and there was
a pandemic and i was like
can i call a lift to get out of town and
i was like you know what
my mom my mom my grandmother rest her
soul passed away and
and gave me like a little bit of a um a
little inheritance so i just saved
that and got a car all right and so i
was going to ask if you want to go get
drinks after this
but yeah i was so oh god that sucked
talk about like that was definitely like
a scarred for life moment
because it was just every thing
all of that trauma was related to a car
so now and it's crazy even to think
because this was all before like
uber and lyft so it's like if you're
drinking and driving out there
like [ __ ] you yeah like seriously
because it is not fun i see those
billboards and it's like
do you like and cost yourself yeah 10
grand
to pay for it yes and like thank god it
was off my record because they were like
we don't have any
evidence or anything and i was like i
mean there were certainly cabs back in
the day but
nothing like the uh availability of
transportation these days
yeah nothing like that there's nothing
like and i mean i couldn't even imagine
like even if
even if i was shit-faced which i was not
that i couldn't even imagine like
hurting somebody like not only are you
drinking under the influence but
like crashing into somebody or running
someone over or like i couldn't even
process that like that just terrifies me
even to think of
so yeah well it's not worth it it's not
worth it call a lift call it over be
responsible
even if you even if you just have a
couple beers in a shot and you're like
i'm good i'm gonna take my friends home
um i want to say there was something um
there was a case i want to say
[ __ ] who was who was it with someone
just got there
oh um bruce springsteen oh yeah bruce
yes he got charged for dui and they
dropped it because they said the machine
malfunctioned
the boss got that yeah it was on twitter
today they were just like oh yeah
the dui charges got dropped because the
the breathalyzer was off so
that [ __ ] happened so i was like two
point eight or two
whatever the hell it was i was like no
no no no no no no no
so yeah there's no way uh let's take a
quick break and tell you about our
sponsor expressvpn now you don't want to
be like that house remember that house
back in the neighborhood that the door
was always open people running in and
out you didn't even know who those kids
were in there they're taking people's
food their pets everything you don't
want to be like that
you got to lock your stuff down why use
expressvpn because
expressvpn creates a secure encrypted
tunnel
between your device and the internet so
your online activity can't be seen by
anyone
it's as easy as closing your front door
all right here's what you do you fire up
the app
and you click one button okay it's rated
number one by c
net wired and the verge it works on
phones laptops even routers
so everyone who shares your wi-fi can be
protected
all right i use expressvpn all the time
i don't i have it on actually i just got
a new um modem and router from spectrum
and we put it on here at the office
and at home and it just protects you it
keeps you safe out there
and nobody jumping in on that that wi-fi
we need to upload this video to you
every tuesday
secure your online activity by visiting
expressvpn.com
honeydew today that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-v-p-n.com
honeydew and you can get an extra three
months for free
expressvpn.com honeydew
now let's get back to the do um tell me
about this blacklisting story
okay speaking of alcohol
oh this is one of those moments that i
can now
laugh at because it was so long ago
but at the time oh my this [ __ ]
stayed with me for about three years
um there was a little show on the air
called chelsea lately
mm-hmm i wrote promos for yeah everyone
worked on it
it was kind of at that at the height of
e
um entertainment i mean
i felt like that was kind of like the
the carson of the new millennium
i guess like it was just like oh you're
gonna go on chelsea what a great honor
you're gonna get so many fans and
you're gonna go on tour and your life
will change so
um i've talked about this on a couple
podcasts but i'm you know i'm excited to
go in depth with you
um i love it i love it
uh let's see let's see let's see so i
started doing
i got passed to the comedy store in
2009.
so this was probably about 2010 or 11 i
would say
um
a comic friend
asked me to go meet her comic friend at
the time
asked me to meet her for um
lunch at this restaurant in
west hollywood and she proposed this job
for me because she was going to get her
own show on
e and she was looking for a co-host and
she thought it was
would be great with me because we could
banter i'm gay
people love gay people in the midwest
um and uh
it was gonna be this like fun
spin-off show for you know uh so every
white woman could
have their own gay at home and um
i would like i remember leaving i
remember walking home
walking walking home calling my mom and
was like this is
it it's happening we're doing it and
afterwards she invited me to go to
uh a taping of chelsea and i remember
like oh my god here it is it's happening
oh [ __ ]
and i remember getting there and i
remember seeing chelsea handler and
the the first thing that chelsea came i
didn't even like
say hello she just looked at me and goes
are you gay and i was like yeah and she
goes i knew it and i'm like
but you can also hear my voice right
like
you're not a sleuth like
when you see a guy at your show you
automatically assume they're gay because
you know it's chelsea lately and you're
on the e network i mean come on
um so i'm watching the taping
and then afterwards uh the friend
is like hey i got an invitation to the
christmas party would you want to go and
i'm like [ __ ] yeah she's like you know
we're just going to ease you in
we're going to get you on the panel on
this show to kind of ease you into the
next show and all this stuff i had met
like all the execs at the time
um you know oh they're all excited like
this is what's gonna happen
and i'm on cloud nine and i'm like oh
this is [ __ ] show
yeah i find like people had been telling
me for the past couple years too like
you gotta get out chelsea you'd be
perfect for it i'm like no
[ __ ] right and um
[Music]
again no car so this person
decides that uh oh well me and my
boyfriend at the time will come pick you
up and we'll go together it's over in
santa monica it's like you know down the
street at this hotel
um and so they come pick me up
very exciting and i remember we pull up
to the hotel
and she said to me she's like oh by the
way
um this party is sponsored by belvedere
because that was chelsea's like favorite
alcohol right and i'm like oh [ __ ]
and i said well just to let you know i
don't want to be that guy and she's like
we're all going to be that guy
verbatim i stand to that this day
like i that those words were exchanged
so i get there and it is just a
who's who of you know chelsea lately
like you know uh heather mcdonald was
there sarah colonna was there
uh josh wolfe uh josh wolfe was there
and uh brad wallach was there
um uh i'm trying to remember who else
just everybody john caparulo at the time
was there um
you know all the agents all the
who's who of the show was there and i'm
nobody right
so i walk in and um
i see the bar
[Laughter]
i'm like oh it's like a whole
wrap-around bar just belvedere ice
sculptures and [ __ ]
there's a photo booth um
and i just remember going to the to the
bar and i
i you know had something and
it gets rowdy it gets rowdy to the point
where i
think no i don't think i know
that the dj had left the dj booth
to go pretend it was [ __ ] tijuana
mexico
and pour shots down our throats to a
black-eyed peas song
okay that's how drunk i was all right i
was enjoying the black-eyed peas
which to me the black-eyed peas are the
wiggles for adults
[Music]
like i
the best goddamn comparison i've ever
heard
like it's so perfect man that is so
sweet
i just like that's how you know you're
drunk when the black eyed peas are on
and you're like i got this guys
ladies like no no no no no no no no
no
no that is some kids bot voodoo
all right no thank you
so no one has seen chelsea yet
um and mind you i'm not friends with
a lot of the the people on chelsea now i
am like i'm friends with heather and you
know josh wolf and you know everybody's
kind of worked on it i now know
um but we were all so [ __ ] up so
[ __ ] up everybody
um so
i'm like well where's chelsea chelsea's
not there yet chelsea at the time was
dating 50 cent
so 50 cent had not shown up
and she wasn't drinking so 50 cent did
not show up but his posse showed up
so people were just like what the [ __ ]
what do we do everyone's like scrambling
like oh you know it smells like weed in
the hotel now and everyone's like ah
of course so i go up to chelsea and i'm
like i just want to tell you know
okay yeah and i remember some guy
pushing me
away that's it
that's all you remember that's it
i remember waking up the next morning
in my bed in my apartment
goals and i swear not even hungover like
i
literally i the way i describe this
story is i woke up like snow white like
it literally was like
what a wonderful party like the
bluebirds came in they're like did you
have fun i
sure did like it was like a disney
magic moment like the deer came up and
was like here's your water justin i'm
like uh
and i texted him i texted the person i
went to the party with and i'm like oh
my god thank you so much for a wonderful
time it was great
the response i get was oof and i'm like
oof
what do you mean oof don't oof me
she writes back you got kicked out of
the party and i'm like
what do you what do you mean i got
kicked out of the party i don't know
what do you mean you don't know we don't
know what happened you just got kicked
out of the party
now i'm freaking out because i'm like
why would i get kicked out of a party
people love me
i'm the life of a party what what
happened like did i fight somebody did i
yeah what happened
all of the people that i followed on
twitter at the time
who followed me back on twitter all of
them unfollowed me
whoa morning all of them unfollowed me
and i was like [ __ ] this is serious
that week i was supposed to do
the show gone
um it got to the point where i was at
the comedy store and i saw the person
who invited me
she stopped talking to me all together
would ignore me
it got to the point where i was like hey
like what's going on to
the point where i was like am i insane
am i an insane person at this point
uh yeah i haven't heard anything about
the show so uh
gotta go right because you're supposed
to do a show with this person
yeah right who you know very well
tell me later um
so i'm like freaking out cause i'm like
am i a disaster
like what happened no one's giving me
any
hearsay it's just go along with it shut
the [ __ ] up
you're not you're never doing chelsea
lately
um a couple years go by so i said like
three years go by wow and mind you i had
i had left my manager got a new manager
got left a manager got a new manager and
in that three years
no one told you what the [ __ ] happened
no nobody no one
no one but every new manager was like
martindale i got it you're going to do
chelsea lately and i was like
[Laughter]
good luck i was like by all means you
can try
so michael cox who used to book chelsea
lately
he would get a call from my manager
every time
and be like hey you know we want to get
justin martin on the show and he was
like
marnell's never doing chelsea lately he
knows why and i'm like but i don't i
don't know why i don't know why
so i gave up so there's one night where
i'm performing in la jolla
um and fortune themed store's with me
fortune just got hired as a
writer for the show so she's like i just
got i got hired as a writer for the show
like congratulations now you have to
find out
right over what exactly your first job
shall you accept to take it
you have to find out what the [ __ ] i did
at the party because she wasn't even
there
and she's like okay i'll find out so i'm
like okay good find out
finally three years three years later
and like
demons i mean just the depression i'm
like i'm over like no one's gonna hire
me no one's gonna give me a job i'm
never gonna work for e
i'm ruined i'm a ruined scorned woman
[Laughter]
woman i can't give my husband a child
um it's a girl you wanted a son
in the river um the uh
finally fortune hits me up and she's
like i found out what happened and i'm
like
oh my god girl tell me everything she's
like
yeah um i asked heather mcdonald what
you did and she just said you were
really drunk and chelsea was sober and
she wasn't having it and i'm like
what and she's like yeah you were just
drunk and
chelsea was mad that 50 didn't show up
and
you were just annoying her and she just
kicked you out
i'm like
you mean to tell me that a woman who's
based her career off being a [ __ ]
alcoholic mess
kicked me out of her christmas party
she's like
yeah and i'm like okay
it's pretty lame to be honest but is
that really the extent of it
that's pretty yeah that was exactly what
happened that was she was like
she was there she was mad there was no
word back that you said something
offensive or did something offensive
you're just
way too drunk i was just too drunk i was
just too shit-faced
and i guess i might have been like you
know
stumbly or you know and she's like uh
get this guy out of here blah blah blah
blah
oh i left out that that was the
christmas party so i
went home for uh
christmas and when i got home chelsea
lately was on
and chelsea's doing her monologue and i
swear to god i'm watching with my mom
you know and chelsea looks at the camera
and she's like for the first time ever
in chelsea lately christmas
party history i kicked a drunk guy out
of my party no way
cuts to a picture of chelsea and
the person i went to the party with with
chelsea's thong
in her mouth pulling it like you know
the copper tone baby
and i'm in the background just going
but again it's not it's not me being
shitty it's just literally me just doing
the home alone face
and i'm like oh [ __ ] i made the
monologue and my mom just
just looks over at me and i'm like oh my
god oh my god so that
that experience [ __ ] with me that's
your credit
yeah chelsea lately you did do it
goddamn
i made the monologue but i mean
definitely put a weird damper on that on
that friendship because i won't i even
want to say like i saw this person
in the hallway before the pandemic and
uh she brought me up on stage once and
was just like i had to follow her
and she was like who's next and they're
like justin martindale and
and um she's like oh my god i love this
guy i love watching him he's so funny
i can't wait to sit in the back and
watch him he's going to be great you're
going to love him justin martial
and i get up there and i go is she still
in the room
no she left oh i'm so glad she uh she
decided to stay in the back and watch me
yeah yeah like just full of [ __ ] just
such bs
and uh there was a moment in the hallway
where i was like hey i know like we've
had like a couple of years now
of this weird like tension or whatever
but like i just want to say
it is what it is i can laugh about it
now and we're fine i had a show at e
on snapchat so it did suck but like
it is what it was and you know i kind of
feel like
and they replaced me with somebody else
for her show and her show got cancelled
so
cool hey i mean hollywood am i right
hollywood but yes i'm like ugh people
are like what
what would you say to chelsea if if you
saw her today and i'm like i'm not
like we're fine what do i say
i was the one like there's no
well you mentioned hollywood and you
said that uh you had some stories from
your hollywood twink days as you say
now please explain to everyone out there
what a twink is
because i had to look it up only a
handful of years ago you looked up twink
yeah i had it for you i had never heard
i i've never heard that term you've
never heard of a twink
not until probably like when i was like
42 or 43 it got by me that long
well well you know what a bear is right
of course i know what a bear is it's
like a you know
just pick an animal i don't know what
exactly i think a twink is just twinka
is just a young
slender bear could be yes
like i don't have body hair like i just
have never had body hair i've never had
to shave my chest
nothing so hairless is hairless like
like a like a young
like a young peter pan
he's already young that's the whole
point
he never grew up never grow up how old
are you 98.
what a young peter just a young like a
young like if you see
like it's like it's like like in the
early 2000s it was like that emo
kid just really soft skin and and like
this big around just skinny
like elf looking you know
so yeah so i mentioned the second time i
moved out to l.a so the first time
i moved out to la was um
[Music]
um definitely an experience
i had my space was still a thing okay
um i was
uh i kind of got involved with this
group
of guys that were just very very very
very hollywood
um monday we would do this tuesday we'd
go here
wednesday we'd go here thursday we go
how many of you would you say
there's probably about like seven to 10
of us
i guess and was everyone a twink
is it okay for me to say 20 you can say
negative term yeah yeah oh hold on
oh you just got cancelled so sorry you
imagine if i get cancer from
asking if i can say dwight the twin
community is outraged
that's how this is yeah i'm so sorry he
got canceled for asking
me yeah so sorry he tried to be an ally
guys but
just turned out to be an [ __ ]
[Music]
um
oh my god
[Laughter]
i'm sick sick of sickler
sick of them oh so i end up
going out how old are you by the way i
mean [ __ ] i was 20 this was true
yeah this was like 21 22. this is
you're going tomorrow this goes into the
first summer
of tahoe so
i'm living with two of my roommates from
texas we moved into this apartment
in um palms i think
and um uh
got a job and around that same time is
when i met my dad
from the first honeydew episode where i
went to
tijuana and all that [ __ ] so i had met
these guys we're partying every night
we're doing cocaine
we're drinking apple martinis oh
god those were the days
watching sex in the city and like i mean
just raging and they lived in hollywood
and i lived in palms so it's like i
would just stay there
like kind of on these like benders so i
didn't have to drive back and forth
and um
one night one night
we went to this party and this guy was
there
and he was a photographer i know the
photographers yeah
it's the photographers and the guys that
are selling speakers
those two crews out there yeah
and things you want to hear as a young
20 year old
gay kid in la is have you ever thought
about modeling and i'm like oh
have i
i am so glad you asked
[Music]
um so we're just i mean we are just
gacked out of our minds me and i want to
say was like three of the friends
and we are in a shower
naked but we're not doing anything with
each other
um i'm so sorry i feel like a lot of
your audience might have turned off
no we're good okay good stay with me
guys um
we're in a shower and we are just posing
like we are in a
[ __ ] abercrombie and fitch like
remember abercrombie and fitch when they
were like we sell clothes but everyone's
naked yes
and you're like what what clothes do you
sell that guy's not wearing it yeah
why are there more pubes than clothes um
and is it like a glass shower or you
guys all like we have the door
open and this guy is just like taking
pictures and i am just
brooding and giving you cheekbones i'm
giving you
angles all of that naked with two other
guys yeah but
i feel like we i feel it uh i feel like
i was covering it up but
probably not my dong's out there
somewhere it's out there um
so i find out that this
like years and years and years later um
i want to say i ran into that guy the
photographer
and he was like oh yeah
um i was over at brian singer's house
and he has that picture of you guys over
over his fireplace
and i was like what this is and now i'm
like a full
adult right yeah i'm like but it always
every now and then i'm just like
is that still there i like i'm wondering
you know when he's gotten into some
trouble with like some some you know
young guys but i was like oh [ __ ]
because i mean i looked good in the
pictures i'm
sure but still i'm just like am i
am i at brian singer's house over his
mantle
then there's another story and i've
never i've
i've never told this story all right so
i'm like that might feel exclusive here
yeah so god i don't even remember where
i
met this dude like so i
um this guy got in contact with me
because this is [ __ ] i want to say this
might have been like
craigslist or i don't even know remember
uh craigslist
i know how was i not murdered because of
used craigslist i can't believe you
weren't i can't believe you were
murdered i know brutally thank you and
like butchered and weird
thank you and your dead body
so this guy's like hey i'm a um model
it's called craigslist it's a guy named
craig who's incredible
what is this list is it actual
paper or is it like on a mirror you know
so this guy hits me up and he's like i'm
a um
i'm a model scout and i'm like
and he's like um i'm visiting from san
francisco um
i would love to talk to you about
getting into
modeling out here and i was like all
right cool so he's like come meet me
at the w hotel in westwood and
i'd love to like grab a drink and we can
talk it up so i'm like alright cool
so show up he's in the lobby and he's
probably about like
he's like mid
40s like doesn't look like a model scout
but like
i don't know what a model scout i mean
anyone can look like a model scout
exactly um so we're having like a
martini he's talking to me like you got
a great look and you know you're you
know
you have a good uh a good frame you got
a good
uh body that's in right now and i'm like
twink
twink martindale um
[Music]
so he's like okay how about this i'm
going to go across
i'm staying at i don't even know
it was like a house but it was right
across from the w
he's like i'm staying right over here
let me let me
uh sign out on the tab and everything
you come meet me over
over uh at the place after this so i'm
like okay cool
so i walk over there i walk in it is
like
dimly lit um
and he's you know he has his clothes on
and uh
he starts like talking to me and he he
pulls out these magazines and he's like
ripping out the pages and he's like you
could do this
you could do that you could even do this
and i'm just like
what what like what is this and he's
like yeah you know like i feel like you
could
you're very you could you have a nice
range you could do these type of
shots but he's not showing you a
portfolio not showing me a portfolio
tearing that [ __ ] out of him
[ __ ] out of a magazine and i'm like oh
[ __ ]
like like the gears start going and i'm
like oh
god this guy is full of [ __ ] and um
then it starts getting into like
take his shirt off let me see what's
going on what are you working with there
and i'm like oh
fine take off my shirt he's like all
right now let's see like what could you
if you could do like bathing suit are
you wearing boxers you're doing briefs
could they like look like a bathing suit
like a speedo and like some trunks and i
was like
i don't even remember what i was wearing
so i took him off and i'm like in my
underwear in front of the sky
and he starts coming over he like walks
over to me and he's like just relax just
relax just rub in my shoulders
and i'm like i'm okay like everything's
fine and he's like
okay no like you know get on the bed let
me take some pictures and i'm like is
this going into brian singer's house
because i swear to god
[Laughter]
he knows me he knows me
i'm not doing this again so he starts
taking pictures of me
and at this point i'm just kind of
playing along i'm just like i'm in
westwood might as well you know like i'm
not driving
like where am i going um
so then it gets to the point where he
takes off my underwear and starts
jerking me off
so that's where i'm kind of like again
i'm in westwood
why not that's your bernie made the
drive
[Laughter]
like i know it's weird but i'm like i'm
in westwood
so he starts like like he's jerking me
off and
i it's weird but at the same time i'm
like
just close your eyes and go with the
flow like i was taking pictures of this
probably i'm sure again again the dong
is out there
i'm gonna do my own spin-off show called
the honey dong and
justin martindong it's a great dog i
have a great dog
how about you it's a good it's a girthy
like
bro you're 6'4 your dick's even halfway
proportionate it's like a good can of
biscuits
you know it's
oh god
this this podcast is sponsored by
bisquick
um so you know
he i finished i finish and but it
doesn't go any further it doesn't go any
further than that it's just a handy
and uh then he's like
you know then we have to say goodbye you
know which is always the worst
and he's like uh yeah you know i i have
to get back to san francisco
uh tomorrow you know i have something
with my wife and son
what why even say it why are you even
saying
because i think it was him
trying to pass off that that what just
happened you know
sexual assault was him being
professional
like oh i just wanted to you know and
just led to this happens
you know and i'm just like uh okay you
know i'm just this young
you know stunning
[Music]
elf-like tweet
is this a renaissance fair no that's
just how he looks
and so so i remember like he gathered up
are you leaving that night i left that
night yeah no there was no staying okay
but i just remember being like i went
home and i was just like
what the [ __ ] just happened and then
um you never saw these pictures never
saw never saw anything again and i want
to know if this guy is like still around
i mean i wish i remembered his name i
wish i knew like
what the hell happened how many other
guys you know we had a me too movement
and everyone's like ah
i'm gonna i'm gonna start the he too
movement
because i feel like there's a lot
there's a lot you always hear about like
gay for pay
and like all these guys but again i
wasn't like
outraged by it it was kind of hot at the
same time because
it was like this stranger but again how
[ __ ] stupid am i like i could have
been murdered that night he's like
you never you never know you never know
and like
i mean thank god because after after
i want to say after that happened i was
hanging around these guys a couple more
times
and i went back home and my roommates
like had all my [ __ ] out on the
apartment on the on the steps
they were like you got to get out of
here dude like you're a mess like these
are my friends from back home like they
took
all my clothes belongings
and put it out on the curb and were like
waiting for me to drive up and they were
like
you got to go i kicked you out kicked me
out and it was the best thing that could
have happened to me
because um
i loaded my car up and i remember our
downstairs neighbor was this old lady i
don't even remember her name i don't
even know she's still alive
um but her like male companion
um the sweetest guy
uh he gave me like twenty dollars and he
was like
he's like go take care of yourself like
get some help and do that and so luckily
thank god i had an aunt who lived out
like like out in like
uh like san dimas area okay
so i stayed with her which was
technically kind of like a rehab i
looked at it as like a rehab like hey
like i'm drinking too much i'm doing
drugs like why am i doing drugs why am i
doing drugs
i'm just like like like letting people
just have their way with my body
um i wish i could say the same now but
but like it it literally was like
a reset and i'm very thankful that like
you know they could have saved my life
when you think about it that way yeah
and then i remember like that
spring is when i got on the computer
um got on craigslist and found an
audition
in nevada city no two that's when it all
started go audition for
the first production that they were
doing that year
so i went up there got it got the part
and packed up all my [ __ ] and was up
there all summer
with a bunch of people who were just
like me who were
amazing who just like took me in
believed in me
you know and you just kind of like
rebuild your character yeah it makes a
difference yeah yes
so that was that was the the book end
right there
oh man i'm glad it worked out and thank
you for
um you're the [ __ ] you know i love you i
love you any time you want
all right please come up with more
stories i'm sure you don't have to dig
2d
um promote your podcast and everything
again please yes please uh
my podcast is called glitter and garbage
with justine moreno
and it's pop culturey it's you know
what's everybody watching what's
everybody talking about it's on spotify
and itunes so please
like us and subscribe all right uh as
always ryan sickler on all social media
ryan sickler.com
we'll talk to you all next week
[Music]
you